- Alright, come on everybody, come on in,
let's go, let's go.
Free candy, I brought candy.
(chuckles) Okay, everybody, great.
Everybody, welcome to
the first annual company
guess-o-ween costume parade.
(unenthusiastic applause)
(woman screaming)
Okay, now let's let
these festivities begin!
Come on up, who's first?
Here we go and now, why
don't you tell everybody
your name?
- It's Rebecca, you know that.
- Okay but maybe some people don't know.
- I've worked here for three years.
- Okay, okay, lovely Rebecca
dressed as Rosie the Riveter.
Stay riveting, madame.
Haha, wonderful, great.
Oh, looks like we got a storm a'brewing.
Captain Jack Sparrow.
Sorry, we don't have any alcohol here.
- Cool, can I sit down now?
- Come on, do the line.
- Why?
- Just do it.
- But why is rum gone?
- Captain Jack Sparrow!
Oh, and now we have the
illustrious and beautiful
Tisha Campbell from Oscar night.
- I'm pretty sure she's Cinderella.
- What?
No, Cinderella's whiii-
te gloves are missing.
- Cinderella wears blue gloves.
- Okay moving on, moving
on, thank you very much.
- So retarded.
- Here we go, Winston Churchill.
Nice.
- What the fuck?
- Don't fight me in the streets,
Ryu from Street Fighter, huh!
Oop, sorry, sorry.
Oh wow, I love this take.
Michelle Yeoh on the Heroic Trio.
- What?
- Yes, I love seeing a younger generation
embrace the classics.
- She's Little Red Riding Hood.
- What, no, impossible.
- That movie came out in '93.
She's younger than that reference.
- Okay, you can't trick
this treat-er, okay?
I think I know my 90's kung-fu movies.
- Actually I'm Little Red Riding Hood.
- Okay, let's get our next contestant up.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Another modern take on a classic,
although I am having a
little trouble finding you.
- Please.
- The influential and always
in the wrong part of town.
- Please don't.
- Black Waldo.
- [Waldo] Ed.
- Okay sorry, African American Waldo.
- [Girl] Oh hell no!
- Come on man, how can you
not see you're being racist
right now?
- What?
I am not racist.
First of all, I'm the boss.
Second of all, I hired
almost all the races.
- Okay, well I'm Waldo.
No need for the distinction.
- But you're black.
And you're Waldo.
- Right, but you didn't
call Tim white Ryu.
- I don't see your point.
- Ryu's Japanese.
- I guess but look at him, I mean,
he looks just like him, we get it.
- Yeah and I look just like Waldo.
We didn't think about race
when we got our costumes,
so why bring it into our title?
- Okay, okay, I think
you're playing the race card
a little heavily here so,
maybe we should all just go back to work
and cool out for the rest of the day.
- Okay.
Who are you dressed as?
- What, come on, I'm Shaft.
From the cult classic Shaft?
You, of all people,
had to have seen Shaft.
What?
Alright, nobody gets any candy.
I'm taking this back home.
I think that went great.